i'm pleased to invite dr uda saksana for
his talk on omni technology in target
selection and drug discovery process
i would like to take the pleasure of
introducing him
dr uda saksana is currently a co-founder
of the startup biotech company reality
innovations he has held executive and
leadership positions at parker davidson
and arbor atherogenics in atlanta as vp
drug discovery dr reddy's laboratory as
chief scientific officer us and india
and carius therapeutic ceo
he has a phd in biochemistry from
memorial university and post-structural
training at columbia university he was
associated with the team at park davis
pfizer that discovered lipter
and atol rastatin the largest selling
peak sales of dollar 17 billion dollars
drug in the pharma business
he let teams that brought several drug
candidates from an idea into the clinic
and we are glad to hear from you sir
over to you
thank you very much
and
thank you mohit um
it's pleasure to be here let me now try
to
play the slides myself i have a 50 50
track record sometimes i'm able to do it
sometimes i'm not i still haven't quite
figured that out but uh
let me try it can you guys see my uh
screen
oh no i have to do a screen share is it
awesome
yes uh how do i oh okay one second
you'll have to let me do it uh it's not
letting me do it right now so
it says one participation
[Music]
okay
can you see it now
uh no sir we can't see it if you click
on the share screen i can it will ask
you this window or a specific slide
check that you would like to share you
can click on it
hola can you yes it's coming
okay thank you
you know you learn uh something new
every day so
it's always a good thing let me now play
all right so now you can see it right
yes
okay thank you yeah once again thank you
pam pine bio for a
very kind invitation and introduction
um as mohit said i'm going to tell you
about omix technologies and
specifically their applications in
target selection and
really all of the drug discovery process
so
i will speak for about 25 minutes or so
and
if there are questions i don't know what
the the what the format is but if there
are questions i'll be happy to take that
so
so briefly i'll talk about i i think i
should introduce drug discovery to this
audience because i'm not so sure what
your backgrounds are so i think i'll go
ahead and do a brief introduction on
what it takes to discover a new medicine
uh then i will plug into that the role
of omix and clearly omix have a huge
role
in discovery of new medicines or drugs
and specifically i want to focus on
proteomics and their its role in drug
discovery
right off the bat i can tell you that 90
of the drugs that we have today have a
protein target in other words if we did
not have proteins
we would not have had a drug so that's
how important proteins are in drug
discovery and as a result of that
proteomics certainly assumed a very
important role in discovery of new
medicines
so this is uh to those of you who may
not be aware but discovery of a new drug
is a very long process and when i say
very long
it takes anywhere from 12 to 15 years
the reason is as follows if you look at
the bottom you will see that
in the purple color starting there are
three phases to it the first phase is
what we call
in vitro and in vivo testing
uh in that basically you start with
identity suppose you want to go after
alzheimer's what you have to do is
figure out what is your target so for
example in alzheimer's
there is something called tau tau is a
protein that gets deposited in the brain
as a result of which it's neurotoxic
and then that causes
alzheimer's so the target for
alzheimer's drug discovery could be the
tau protein and there's a couple
approaches either you can block its
synthesis or you can block its function
either way you can approach it so that's
how it starts it starts with an idea of
what target you want to
go after
and then once you do that as i will
tell you in the next slide there's some
additional things you have to do but
from there it moves on to early
discovery in which the chemists
start to make drugs that might actually
block the function of tau whichever way
you want and then you have to select the
best compound that becomes what's called
a lead drug or a lead compound and then
you have to move into pre-clinical
testing
uh up up until now what i just talked
about is all in vitro and then as we
move into pre-clinical it's mostly in
vivo work starting with demonstrating
that the drug you have chosen actually
works in an animal model of alzheimer's
and there's many animal models of
alzheimer's that you can do
and if it looks good then you have to
move into toxicity testing remember a
drug should not only just be effective
but it also be safe in fact i would say
more than 50 to 60 percent of the drugs
fail
not because they are not active or
efficacious but they're also toxic so
you want a drug that is safe which is
not toxic as well as defecations
once you find that gem you then move it
into clinical development this is in
humans you have three phases phase one
phase two phase three uh phase one is
typically in healthy volunteers and then
phase two in a small population of
alzheimer's phase three is in a very
large population of alzheimer's patients
and oftentimes you also have to compare
it with what what else is out there in
the market
so all of this takes about
the preclinical phase up to the
preclinical phase it might take about
five to six years and the rest of it
really is clinical development which
means all the clinical trials and
something like alzheimer's which
actually progresses very slowly over a
period of years it might take about five
to ten years to do the clinical
development part but other it's
something like covet 19 as we'll talk
about it is an infection and that could
you know you could develop a drug there
much faster than alzheimer's
once you successfully demonstrate that
the drug is safe in humans as well as
the defecations for the disease then you
have to submit what's called a new drug
application to the fda usfda they'll
take about a year to review all of the
data and this is thousands of pages of
data that you have to submit and
eventually then you get uh
then you get approval so it's about 10
to 15 years it's generally half a
billion dollars and the success rate is
very very low
you might start with 10 000 drugs that
you look at but only one is successful
so the probability of success is
extremely low so it's it's you know as
you can see it's a very complicated
process time consuming high risk and
takes a lot of uh money as well so
this is not for you know somebody who is
a weak hearted so drug discovery now you
know why new drugs when they come on the
market might sound expensive and the
reason for that is so much of effort and
money has to go in by the company to
produce a new drug right so this is a
basic format of how new drugs are
discovered you need to know this before
i tell you about how proteomics are
important in this process
so the the number one step that you have
to have as we already talked about in
drug discovery and development is you
have to select a target
and i gave the example you'll see in the
green box it's a strategic research
decision you have to make
so the target could be tau
it could have been you know
amyloid also or there are multiple
targets in the alzheimer's area can go
after
so you have to actually choose one
and
then you have to validate it so what
validation actually means is if you
manipulate the expression of the target
protein
and if it you have to demonstrate its
relationship with the disease so for
example tau if it goes up it causes
alzheimer's so you might take an animal
model or express tau protein in the
brain and demonstrate that you start to
see alzheimer's like symptoms right so
that's target validation so before you
put any money time and effort you have
to validate the target to the
satisfaction of
the company that you are working at
once that is done then you have to set
up some assays
which are basically in vitro essays to
be able to say that if i add a drug tau
function is inhibited or not uh that
process at that point chemists come into
play and you generate drug compounds
that are called hits then you deal lead
identification uh eventually then you
have to test in animals in which you
have to look at add me pk which is
basically once you give the drug to the
animal and eventually to humans you want
to know that it gets to the brain or not
right because that's where it has to act
so that process is called add me pk
and then in clinical trials you have to
kind of repeat a lot of what you did in
the pre-clinical animal studies you have
to kind of duplicate that there so as
you can see it's all depends with the
target that you select if you did not
select the right target which is
robustly involved with the disease
process you are going to fail and the
longer you the longer it takes for you
to fail the more expensive it gets
clinical trials for example are about 80
percent of the cost so off of half a
billion if you fail in clinical trials
then you probably lost about 400 million
dollars it happens like i said the odds
of success are quite low so the target
selection the protein that you want to
go after and its association with the
disease has to be very robustly
demonstrated and convincing so just
showing something in a petri dish and
saying i think this is going to work is
simply not enough because you will that
you're setting yourself for a
failure so
uh everything starts with selecting the
right target and usually as i'll tell
you
uh targets are 99
of the time they're protein so
so how do omics come into play here
before we had the tools of the omics
like the genomics transcriptomics
proteomics and metabolon metabolonomics
it was a little bit of a hit and miss
but now with these very sophisticated
tools you can actually understand the
disease better so to be able to select
the right target right you should
understand the disease process very well
which step in alzheimer's is tau coming
into play does it come into play before
the disease sets in or after the disease
is already set in right because once the
disease is set in
then there is no point in going after
tau so you want to choose something
that's up front and upstream in the
process and it takes a lot of
gene expression
proteomic analysis and all of that so
not only in target selection
as i will tell you does omics come into
play but also now our ability to
understand disease processes with all
these wonderful omics tool that are
listed here has dramatically increased
the likelihood of success of a drug
if you don't have an understanding of
the disease
you will not be successful it is as
simple as that so any tool that you can
use to improve your likelihood of
disease understanding the better off you
are there so not just in drug disco in
in target selection as i'll say but
this understanding the disease itself
all of the omics tools actually have a
fundamental role to play
uh this is just reiterating what i said
i've broken it down more into the
language of drug discovery at the very
bottom you'll see
uh you know starting from lead discovery
target selection and all of that we just
talked about every step of these have
some form of omics being used sometimes
it's genomics sometimes it's trans
ectonomics proteomics or metabonomics so
at every step of drug discovery even in
clinical trials when you are actually
dosing patients with the potential drug
you can get their blood samples and do
an array of omics technologies and try
and better understand if the drug is
working or not so i think in summary for
this slide what i want to say it there
is not one step in the drug discovery
process in which we do not use some form
of comics or not so omics have really
really become very important in our
quest for new medicines and drugs
so of all those that i talked about you
have the genomics proteomics and all of
that i think it's very safe to say that
proteomics probably have the central
role to play in that that's simply
because the target the basis of
designing a drug discovery program
is selecting the right protein and
understanding it in many different ways
its function its validation
uh what happens to it if it drug binds
all of that so proteins to my mind uh
are the
perhaps and proteomics thereby are
perhaps the most important um tools that
we have in drug discovery today
again i'm trying to tell you where
proteomics plays at all obviously target
identification and validation the targus
is a bri is a protein so it's a
no-brainer you'll need also in lead
discovery and optimization i'll tell you
a little bit more later on about that
and molecular docking becomes very
important as the scientists choose which
is the right drug to move forward with
right and then the in vitro and in vivo
studies even to understand drugs
toxicity and efficacy
you want to look at the drug might be
affecting the protein that you want
which is tau for example but it may be
acting on something else that's
fundamentally important some other
protein that looks like cow and which is
very important in day-to-day function
for example in the liver for example and
the drug might be acting on that too so
that's where proteomics comes into play
in understanding what else is the drug
doing beside what it is supposed to do
is it doing something harmful or not and
uh bio and in the clinical trials i
already talked the number one thing that
proteomics we use for in the clinical
trials is the biomarkers we use the
biomarkers to select patients to
select how much to dose how much dose to
drug with and finally to know whether
they treat they're responding to
the patients are responding to the
treatment or not so
within all the omics tools that are
available to us in a drug discovery
program that is targeted against a
protein i would say proteomics really is
the fundamental backbone of how we move
forward in drug discovery
this is just reiterating the name so one
you might ask why are why is there so
much protein why is there so much focus
on the protein and i'll come to that one
of the things that not all genes produce
the genes produce proteins right certain
genes may never produce any protein so
it's not that simple to go after a gene
target the way to go after a gene target
would be to go after transcription
factor for example
then you know that there is going to be
some protein expression so uh proteins
really are fundamentally the backbone of
drug discovery upstream things like rna
and dna transcription and translation
are slowly becoming important but
to the best of my knowledge 90 plus
percent of the drugs today focus on
protein and that's why protonics become
such an important tool
so what makes a protein a target right a
protein could be an enzyme a lot of the
kinase protein tyrosine kinase acetone
theory serine threonine kinases these
are all wonderful targets enzymes
actually make beautiful targets simply
because uh you know they have an active
site and using proteomics you can
understand and
x-ray crystal structure you can
understand what that active site is what
are the amino acids involved and you can
design a drug so enzymes make wonderful
protein targets
structural proteins sometimes like
dystrophin in duchenne's muscular
disease uh dystrophin is the structure
of protein it's very rare but sometimes
targets can structural protein receptor
and we'll talk about sarcoid too where
the whole field will focus on disrupting
the
as2 binding to the spike protein right
so that's a receptor ligand uh type of
thing and it's very easy to antagonize
and lastly as i said sometimes in this
is happening more in the inflammation
field a transcription factor that might
actually regulate the expression of a
certain protein might become a target so
these are typically some of the
categories of protein targets that the
industry likes to go after
how do we select the target now you know
what a target is it's got a protein with
all the properties at all how do you
select the one you want to go after i
tell you you want uh to select a target
that is the only protein in that so
if you select a kinase target for
example right the problem with kinase
although we have been successful is
there are probably 50 plus kinases so
first of all you have to go after the
right one and then show that's highly
specific for that one so because to
avoid all that we like to go after a
single protein for example tau is a
great example there is no other protein
like tau so going after tau is a
no-brainer for that reason
uh the other and this is the validation
i talked about it has to be directly
associated with causing the disease
it cannot be a phenomenology or it
cannot be anecdotal it has to be
directly which means if i up regulate
that the disease should get worse if i
inhibit the function the disease should
should actually get much better so
that's how it is that you want a target
that is directly related
uh the other thing that you want is that
you want your target only to be
expressed in the disease organ
and that is done to actually limit the
side effects you might get again going
back to the tau example tau is only
expressed in the brain it's never
expressed in the muscle or a kidney or
there so if you manipulate tau it's
unlikely that you are going to affect
other organs so
expression of your target protein only
in the disease organ is a wonderful
wonderful thing to have
uh the other interesting thing when we
select targets which is that
we like to inhibit the function that's
why i said enzymes make beautiful
targets because there's an active site i
can design a drug that'll go bind to it
inhibit its function
on the other side is trying to increase
the activity of an enzyme it's very
difficult it has to be done through an
allosteric mechanism not through the
active site generally and we don't like
that because those are much harder to
design so you pref we prefer to have
things to be inhibited not to be
not to
upregulate their function but down
regularly
the last thing that and this is a really
nice thing to have is we like to have
protein targets that are actually on the
cell surface
so receptor ligands make fantastic
targets also for that reason why is that
the reason is in that case the drug
doesn't have to get into the cell or
into the organ
you know the organ
especially for alzheimer's is something
called a blood-brain barrier and it
doesn't let drugs to get into the brain
at all so oftentimes you don't have
drugs that can get into the cell but if
you have it a cell surface target it's a
whole lot easier so that's so these are
some of the simple criteria uh and uh
omix proteomics specifically comes into
a hugely into deciding uh some of these
uh target selection as well
okay so how do uh drugs interact with
protein targets so here's an example i'm
showing you uh with the family of
enzymes or tanki raises and uh first of
all now with if the crystal structure of
the target is available it makes our job
very much easier because we know what is
the active site and we can then take
that active site with the all the
different amino acids
we'll talk about it moral how it forms a
pocket and all that but virtually in
silico we can actually then select uh
compounds that are already there that
might fit into that pocket or not so up
front itself we could probably screen
50 thousand hundred thousand in silicon
compounds that can fit into the pocket
of the exit side of the enzyme and then
only work on those out of those maybe
only hundred might actually fit very
well so your job is now shrunk down from
having to deal with 100 000 compounds to
about dealing with 100 compounds so
having a crystal structure
is a very important and usually the most
useful thing you can have when you have
selected your target
okay i want to now move on to how we
apply how proteomics has been applied to
a disease that now we are all familiar
with which is sarcoid 2 driven covet so
what are the key features of source cov2
on the very left-hand side you will see
everybody has heard of spike protein so
this is the virus and the way it engages
with the host cells human host cells is
through a protein called
spike protein how does it engage with
the host cells how does it get into the
respiratory system how does it get into
the lungs is through a receptor called
h2 that you see so if you look at the
second box there's a sarscovi 2 with the
spiked protein sticking out and then you
have ace2 receptors this is a counter
receptor protein that's present on a lot
of different cells in the body the
endothelium the lung is pretty much
ubiquitous so therefore you know
although the focus of covid has been on
the lung you will know now that long
covet which is the effects of covet that
come
a few months after the covet infection
can be affecting the kidney the heart
because they all have a stew there so
the virus can enter all of those organs
so the virus binds to the ac2 receptor
and as shown in the third box that's how
it gains entry into the cells and it
creates a mayhem from there as you know
the cytokine storm
the inflammation and as well as the
thrombosis that sets in so a key feature
of sars cov2
uh infection is driven by two proteins
one is spiked protein on the sarcophagu
to reset a virus and the other is the
human as2 receptor
so as you can imagine most of the
targets for covet are actually related
to either h2 or the
spike protein on the left hand side you
will see
strategies that target as2 receptors
strategy one could be to create soluble
forms of the spike protein within the
spike protein as you'll see there's a
specific domain called receptor binding
domain that engages with these two so
one strategy that's being attempted is
to design soluble rb2 rbd rbd so this
will bind to as2 so the actual virus
cannot bind
uh you can also actually make soluble a
stew for example so the ace ii soluble
simply means it's floating around it's
not bound to the virus or not bound to
any um
organ so it's floating around in the
blood it'll see the virus it'll bind it
as a result of which the virus by using
both these strategies as is shown on the
second
figure there uh you can see that there
that the virus cannot engage with as2
and basically if the virus cannot enter
the human cell it's dead there's nothing
it can do
vice versa you can also have strategies
to attack the rbd and this which is the
domain on the spike protein that's
important in binding uh the virus to as2
and rbd has become the number one target
protein
or
target protein region for covid19
whether it's vaccines whether it's
diagnostics whether it's new drugs
everybody is focusing on rbd including
the virus the virus is also focusing in
rbd and when i say that what it's doing
is it's mutating the rbd region to gain
superiority so i try and escape from the
host defense mechanism so the whole
world of sarskowi to covet is actually
focusing on this region called rbd which
lies within spike protein very
interesting portion of that protein this
rbds and i'll tell you why
so this is just to show you the
structure of spike protein so spike
protein is actually sits on the surface
of the virus it's a part of it is into
the virus but most of it is outside
um so that it can bind to go and grab
ace2
as you can see here the spiked protein
has actually been broken down into
spiked protein s1 spike protein s2 spike
protein s1 the s1 is really where the
rbd uh you can see that in the green
rbd lies there it's on the outside of
the uh cells
of the virus uh particles and uh so that
it can go and grab on to as2
all right uh the other parts are there's
also an enzyme too
which is called tempress i mean it's a
i'm giving you a short form that allows
once the h2 is bound to by rbd of the
spike protein then these rest of the
ancillary proteins come into play and
make sure the virus can successfully get
itself into it
right so rvd is really the star of the
movie if you are somebody where to make
a movie on sarsko we two slash kovit rvd
would be the hero i think
yeah so this is just to reiterate that
uh again in the orange you will see the
virus and then you see uh the spikes
coming out that's the spike protein and
on the human cell you'll see as2 and i
just want to reiterate everything we are
doing today to combat sarcoid ii slash
kovid is targeting this protein whether
it is vaccines all of the vaccine either
using a nucleic acid approach or using a
protein subunit approach the antigen
that's going to be used in the vaccines
is rbd there's nothing else some people
use full spike protein but a lot of them
use rbd the idea is if you
either vaccinate with rbd or produce rbd
human body in small amounts you start to
have neutralizing antibodies that come
into play which will stop the binding of
the virus to h2 same with diagnostics
you know the
there are many diagnostics now which is
the rapid antigen test or the rat test
you've heard what are they detecting
they are detecting spiked proteins
and the drugs i mean there are many
drugs that some of them we have worked
on and published are also focusing on
that so rbd interaction with h2
is fundamentally the target for
everything that's going on on sarsko we
too
so why is rbd so important or so
interesting well i already said it's
important because that's what makes the
virus enter into the whole cell beyond
that the virus is very smart it once you
have developed a vaccine against the
original strain right what happens is
that
once you have the original strain
once you have the original strain and
and you find a vaccine to it
if the antibodies to the original strain
rbd
will actually neutralize it so the virus
has started to mutate itself in the rbd
region
you have originally we had the alpha
then you have beta gamma delta and
omicron
the one big change in all of this are
the mutations are occurring so the
viruses figured out that if i mutate
change some amino acids in this area
then i might be able to escape
the
neutralizing antibodies that's being
produced by these humans in response to
vaccines so it's trying to constantly
outsmart the humans by doing that so not
only does it escape the vaccine when it
actually changes or mutates certain
amino acids
all of the mutations that are have a
detrimental effect are in the rbd region
to the best of our knowledge every
single one of them delta omicron gamma
they're all in the rbd region and some
of them make the virus bind tighter to
the ace receptor as a result of which
they can enter but they're more
transable
some of the
mutations make them lose the
neutralizing activity and i'll tell you
about that too so just remember the take
home from this slide is rbd mutations
are fundamental to how the virus has
been mutated has been moving forward all
these times
all right so one of the things you will
see is some you may have had the word
called escape mutations there's a big
problem what are escape mutations escape
mutations are nothing but mutations in
the rbd of the virus that actually cause
the mutant mutated virus not to be
neutralized by existing antibodies so
just to show you in the box here we
created vaccine against the
wild type rbd right and that we were
able to neutralize the virus mutated
itself it created something called
b1.351
when this happened the one dot the
neutralizing activity slightly decreased
so delta actually slightly decreased the
neutralizing activity that was generated
against the original wild type didn't
fit very well
with the
delta for example and so not all the
neutralizing could happen so the virus
could escape
actually things got even worse with
omega now there is about 39 mutations
plus in the rbd and they seem to be new
they seem to be escaping all antibodies
produced by the vaccines to the wild
type so you can see that having small
changes in the rbd substitution of
certain amino acids gives a huge upper
hand to the virus in escaping and that's
why they are called escape mutations
escaping the neutralizing antibodies
that we are producing
so sometimes what happens is we are
giving ourselves a booster i mean
recently in the hope that maybe having
higher titres of antibodies might stop
the omicron we don't know how it's going
to happen but omicron is clearly is not
being neutralized by most of the vaccine
related
antibodies that have been created
so the virus won there so far that has
won you know if with the wild type and
delta we are very happy because the
vaccines work pretty much nicely omicron
we have started to see some issues
so why is the vaccine success depend on
protein antibody interactions so again
having a crystal structure or structure
of these the rbd domain as well as the
antibodies becomes very important what
i'm showing you here in the green is the
rbd
and then i'm showing you breaking that
dot blowing that up a little bit
is that there are different epitopes
epitopes are just regions of
a protein to which antibodies bind and
because of the mutations that have
happened the epitopes are changing you
know when you mutate a protein the amino
acids change right the structure also
changes
inevitable that the structure will
change once the structure changes the
original epitopes to which you designed
your vaccine might be hidden or might be
lost or might not no longer be
recognizable so that's why
you know this interaction between the
antibody and the vaccine
pretty much dictates the success of your
vaccine
right so if there is too many mutations
in the antigen and your antibodies
cannot dock very nicely
that vaccine is going to fail
i want to move on and tell you about
how omix and protein drug interactions
are important
in for and from the basis of small
molecule drugs also i talked a lot about
vaccine but even in designing small
molecule drugs
the interaction of a drug and protein is
very important here's an example so this
is the structure of a drug and what is
important here is how will the drug fit
and bind to the protein in a region of
your interest and usually the
interaction between a drug and a protein
are either hydrophobic which means that
there are hydrophobic amino acids there
and you know your drug might have some
hydrophobicity
so there'll be an interaction there the
other types of interaction hydrophilic
there might be charged amino acids on
the uh for example an enzyme in in the
active site and the drug will have to
have charged amino acids and interaction
there so there's hydrogen bonding
there's electrostatic hydrophilic
hydrophobic
all of these are important in the
high affinity binding of a drug
to
the protein target so a medicinal
chemist once he has a structure of the
amino acid he will try and tweak the
drugs to see if he can fit into that
pocket so not just in vaccines but the
protein structure and proteomics are
playing a very fundamental role in us
designing drugs as well to make sure
that drugs fits very tightly with the
protein target tau for example
i also want to tell you that omics are
helping us understanding so one in
designing vaccine the other is designing
drugs selecting target i mean all across
the value chain of drug discovery
they're playing a big very big role now
the other big role that omnics are
playing is trying to better understand
the mechanism by which the drug will
work
why do we need to know that why do i
care about what the mechanism the reason
to understand the mechanism by which a
drug works is then you can predict what
could what kind of side effects it might
have so if there is a kinase inhibition
is the mechanism right we know that
there is 50 plus kinases so it's very
possible that your drug might actually
bind to more than one kinase and might
give you side effects so knowing the
mechanism of action is a good way of
predicting the adverse or the side
effect profile and omics have really
played for example here you can see that
this is a huntington disease cell model
shown on the right hand you throw the
compound in and there are a variety of
proteomic technologies you can see uh to
see
two sets of experiments can be done one
is what set of genes are being
upregulated or down regulated by the pro
by the compound right so that gives you
some information the other is where
exactly is it binding and what else
so uh there is a lot of uh
exciting things that are coming in
understanding of mechanical action of
drugs since the omics had arrived a lot
of i mean there is a saying now that a
lot of the drugs that were approved in
the 60s and 70s when we didn't have
these beautiful tools would not have
been approved today because they just
have too many side effects aspirin as an
example today if it were to be large we
know it does so many other things that
you don't need it to do including things
like gastrointestinal bleeding and all
so it's only today or in the recent past
that we've understood that drugs of the
past have many other things to do and
that has only become possible because of
our ability to use genomics proteomics
and metabolomics i would say i think
it's a very very safe statement to make
so in summary i think
yeah um this is my last slide
yeah omics have rapidly become the heart
of drug discovery there's no question
protein targets are the basis of 90 per
plus percent of the drugs uh as you can
see mutations in the protein targets can
cause dramatic changes escape mutations
and proteomics is pretty much useful in
target selection drug selection
mechanism action so long story short uh
you know long-lived omics because of
omics i think the likelihood of success
of drug discovery is going to
dramatically increase so thank you very
much for your time um i don't know if i
exceeded by a couple of minutes or so i
don't know
yeah i did but
don't kill me for that please
i'm done
it was definitely a wonderful talk uh
we have a lot of questions i'll mail you
out sir and then we'll get back to our
participants with those questions
absolutely no problem at all yeah all
right thank you
it was fun being here thank you sonalika
yeah